[Music]
hey happy Friday welcome back to
certified country I'm Sophia lacy
joining me today in the studio is chase
right
[Music]
we've had an interesting over the last
three years and we got a new label we've
got a new song we got a new album the
music's back which is that's exciting
for me and I want to talk a little bit
about your road to music your resume is
absolutely insane not only are you an
acclaimed musician former football star
NASCAR pit crew survivor runner up
fashion designer we use that loosely
that's my accounts I've had such a cool
different experience I think that most
people in life it's just a fortunate
thing for me I've lived in really cool
life I wanted to ask you about this
mantra that you carry with you heads
down eyes up so head down eyes up I was
working out a mirror was right in front
of me I was rehabbing from an ankle
injury I had and I looked in the mirror
my head was down my eyes were up and I
just kind of it I just looked determined
I was like man I said I just caught
myself looking a certain way and so I
just kind of kept saying that to myself
through rehab was head down eyes off
keep going like forget about what
happened to your ankle forget about
what's going on over here and just focus
on the steps you got to do to get better
that's the mentality I kept those head
down eyes up keep going and I held that
on to that through music and I love that
that is a key lyric and Lyons that's
that's right
I'd love to hear some of the stories
behind each of these songs
[Music]
I had the idea for this lambs and lions
I didn't know what it meant and it just
started turning into some funky metal
sound and track and I was like man oh
this feels like something we should
write before a football game funny story
about that we were at JJ Watts farm two
years ago we're just hanging out having
a good time and I played him that song
and I get home a month later I get a
text from JJ saying hey man what was
that song
something about a lion he said I love
that man and so when he said that that
was uh that let me know we hit the mark
that's the foundation that they have
them for sure all right let's get into
the second one on tonight
[Music]
it's one of the few I didn't write when
I heard the song I was like man that
sounds like something I'd have been in
the room to write and everybody's been
in that situation where it's like oh we
on or we off I don't know what's going
on with me and this girl unforgettable
it's about that girl you just can't
forget her know how no matter how long
time goes by
[Music]
no matter
we do if you're there girl
[Music]
iZON use to me is a biggest song of my
career so far that one I can tell you
will be a single first share second
verse says I can't believe him I just
say like let this out the bag but it is
what it does so second verse says
speaking of the coast remember five from
Beach you and me
that's Sunset Cliffs by the sea for my
buddy and I we did a road trip we
stopped him Big Sur and we go to fight
for Beach and we're sitting there the
sunset and we've had a awesome for it
because my college roommate big six
eight probably 300-pound offensive
lineman played in the NFL for ten years
and and I'm sitting there watching the
Sun go down there you know it's the most
perfect scene you can ask for and I'm
kind of just staring at it and also and
I look I look to my to my left I'm like
I don't say it right because I see I see
big Garrett over there just sitting
there like this watching the sunset I'm
like just sharing a casual or this is
the most romantic thing I've ever done
and it's with my big buddy Garrett I
loved so I turned that I flipped it it's
about the girl in the song there we go
that's funny saved me
I've calmed down a little in the last
few years finally you know you grow up
and you learn who you are as a person as
an artist and that's what that song is
about it's about meeting that girl that
kind of wraps grabs you by the neck and
says oh you're coming with me you're
gonna calm down a little bit and no
matter how tough guys are they'll admit
they lament at some point they always
want a girl that'll do that I love this
title one love one kiss one drink one
song yeah and that was not planned
so that's another that's inspired by a
real relationship you know you go
through a breakup and it's like you're
not just over that person right away if
you were that beat it was probably
pretty worthless relationships Jack
Daniels showed up
I wanted a fun song that's me and that's
just energetic and we could do it live
shows our live shows how I built my
entire career so before we ever had
radio we had our live show and people
were showing up so I wanted something
that could supplement the live show and
just and be us be me being the band and
Jack Daniels is is a pretty prevalent
thing that we have on our tour so how
did gets it gets the tip of the hat
every night when I wrote three chords it
was like to me this is a more modern
take on what country is at its roots
right now and some people would argue
that say no the guitars are too loud I
miss the old old days but that's just
where it is right now so I treated that
one more in my mind like it's a real
country song it's too complicated these
days what people are saying what's
country what's not being a day it's
three chords in the truth amen it's the
heart of the record
[Music]
where it stops that's the greatest line
I believe on the record and that's
another one that I didn't write which is
crazy to me because I feel closest to
that one probably than any other song on
the record last one this Cowboys hat
it's one of my favorite songs of all
times so it's a Chris LeDoux song and I
wanted to try to do the best I could
[Music]
so I was like if I screw this thing up
I'm not putting it out I'm not gonna try
I'm not gonna go there and disrespect
Chris like that so my next thought was
what if Ned did it Chris LeDoux his dad
was my childhood hero
so we talked for an hour and a half on
the phone and we go over why I want to
do it how I want to do it we came up
with the idea how about you do the
verses and I did the chorus his son
saying it was just a real area because
it sounds just like it now I want to get
to know you a little bit with this
rapid-fire round first album you ever
purchased the chase by Garth Brooks
first concert you ever attended Garth
Brooks Charlotte North Carolina in 1996
I'm sensing a theme song currently
spinning on repeat 16 by Thomas Rhett
[Music]
if you weren't an artist you'd probably
be doing what changing tires a hundred
motorsport one thing we'd never guessed
by looking at you that I have a
Pinterest account
I had vocal failure and I had two months
where I couldn't do anything so I
honestly this is hard it's embarrassing
to admit I got on Pinterest and I saw
this cool bed that somebody built so I
was like I'm gonna go buy some lumber
and I'm gonna build that bed
so you just taught yourself you just
casually types up a buck Pinterest I
don't make a bed
well I mean I just yeah yeah print first
thank you guys so much for watching if
this is your first time with us please
subscribe to Entertainment Tonight on
YouTube we will be back again next
Friday with a brand new episode of
certified country see you then